oh I'm sure what's up bro what's up
select chef what kind of chef I got Who
am I the green one I just here I'm happy
to start a new game then we're ready to
rock
ready to rock after you do your cooking
with my friends what's with that boy
it's hard to frown and talk at the same
time okay all right no it's not I'm
doing currently you live that life I'm
so happy and nice oh wait oh yeah you
can read the thing that's fine I don't
know yep yep yep make some stuff there's
don't care about the plots a lot wait we
don't care about it but there's bread
zombies they're called the unbraid you
idiot and no we don't care about those
oh that's clever
all right over here we need to do you
see the recipes in the top left there
mark you know how that works yeah yeah I
got I got I got I got yeah
wait you could put wait why are you
doing this why wouldn't I do the plate
was clearly for you there on there I'm a
no please I'm working on it please need
some cukes
I got no plate so there you go oh don't
worry about the plate we'll get it all
set up and ready to go well bobbed yell
at me for not getting on the plane if
there is a plate put it on the plane
don't be an [ __ ] I don't want to
don't be an [ __ ]
oh don't be yourself way but except for
when you're yourself why is wait over
there by himself that seems like the one
thing that we want more
are the one person on that yes
serve it up Marco I got it thanks Marco
Rubio Troy in it if this game was a
child we'd be murdering its parents
right now in a good way
no I fine Marco q how do you show B is -
oh why is speak native plate I got it I
don't have no mark has it
I got faster weight faster weight come
on way let's go nice I serve that
lettuce so loud just like when when the
waiter comes up I love this game but
what horde of unread is eating salads
check your realism developers that's
true I mean there's croutons in the
salad Kevin until we leave how do you do
how you doing just walk up to Kevin you
touch him I'm gonna try to eat Kevin's
food no you touch the [ __ ] out button
it's not a button it's just a thing that
happens when you walk near Kevin Drive
the buzz is that always the thing that
was the thing yeah this is the overworld
no
I'm done this this has been in both
games it should bark I'm not making
funny you enjoy it I thought it was cool
it's fun alright so we're making sad
shimmy of course which is just chop the
shrimps or chop up the fishes
you got it oh hey we're all free I'm
chopping okay here we go
shrim double fish [ __ ] how do
you chop hold square X double issu dumbs
whoa listen all we have no it's sushi me
means no cookie no cookie roast cook
your food no no no no mark you got a
servant in order oh I didn't know that
[ __ ] cuz they're there in order bud
everyone's in order alright I'll be the
plate guy apparently you have
everlasting yeah we don't have to do
dishes yet
that's a later thing double shrimp
double trip I'm on one I got the plates
wait would you I'm murdering you I like
it oh my god put the plate under the
fish more why did you just make that
food on the floor what the [ __ ] is
happening I'm just gonna put plates down
we're gonna play don't worry I'll do
everything that matters we are on fire
fire up there baby I am all about the
fish
oh it's so wacky you know you guys could
just be nice to me you're not earning
throwing [ __ ] everywhere I've earned it
well that's costing us money maybe I
don't know you're gonna give someone
sell vanilla okay mark no oh sorry that
was my bad
that was a sick throw though wasn't it
doesn't say what throws it was a solid
it was a solid chunk there
emote emote apparently we killed it so
you're welcome yeah well I could get
that score on this first level by myself
so don't be too impressed I did this
game is delightful I'm literally gonna
kick you out of the room when I make
merits in this game you warned you
thought I was angry about the audio echo
thing I cause death threats in this game
I have I have I have done things
so we got to cook rice in this one so
rice can burn so careful okay I'm gonna
start chopping fish alright nobody help
with anything that's fine I'm chopping
fish - I'm really chopping it thanks for
the fish we got it you got it you got
there's some more fish on that place
here's a wrap got the rice whose nope
there you go
get the fish rockin get the fish guys
guys us weird it's a it's a small guys
chopping my fish [ __ ] off your fish
chopper why are these people in our
kitchen yeah I don't know what kind of
kitchen this is but it's pretty uh it's
pretty oh wow clearly it's aw I'm gonna
chop your fish for you kind of kitchen
would either complain or be happy oh oh
don't be an [ __ ] II said [ __ ] you
fish chopper no mark here okay no okay
okay okay I was like work team work team
team it makes the thing work [ __ ] you
Wade you were the one who what's wrong
with chopping fish [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
don't care but take this chop fish here
but don't think I'm happy about it okay
all right man whoa whoa okay cool
whoa good job Wade thanks thanks [ __ ]
you thank you [ __ ] thank you
hey guys I love these times were able to
[Laughter]
thank you mean hey guys hey guys were
challenging the first time through and
now it's just so sad how not challenging
why is it sad it's fun it's fun to be
good at things
no it's like I feel bad that we actually
were like the first time through like
the people who made this game don't even
know how to make it challenge
oh no let's a tragedy for them you
people shopping [ __ ]
no I wasn't good at the first time mark
did you just struggle for like 10
seconds it's coming coming up it's
coming up thank you get it get it get it
get it get it
Mervin Hey well done gay 460 Jesus all
right that's pretty good that's pretty
good guys I'm real proud like that wage
is gonna be bad on purpose what do you
mean I killed it with my fish chop it
you did great no with your won't ask me
bad if the game on purpose wait it's
gonna be a bad person on purpose
I'd burn down orphanages I said it we've
all been there we've all been in the
back alley of an orphanage matching hand
gasoline in the other we've all been
there not equal things those dishes wait
now I gotta do dishes another sub mark
well be the dish I'll beat this guy okay
what do I do the dishes shrimp so
they're not up yet once we use them
they'll pop up Rui Rui Rui Rui yeah I
really got to just plain shrimps you can
also throw stuff Marc how do I throw it
hold X to throw yeah can we have a plate
over here yes merci [ __ ] me can you rice
that it could give me a cute oh you gave
me a cute there's some rice I need more
rice over here thank you
look all that one rice is lost forever
in the corner like that can I have a
clean plate mark oh hang on I got
cleaner I need a I need that shrimp on a
plate for me there okay
it's coming up in three two I have no
idea how long it takes you out of the
water and hold X
okay right all this rice is done just
hang a plate coming up in three two one
point and point you so give away the
gift Wade the plates cuz he needs to put
the rice on plates right
that's play rice on this play okay we're
good for you this for now cute I need
some more cukes wait don't worry wait I
got alright
no I got I got my way I need some more
rice over here okay you've got it some
rice I'm doing everything right wait I'm
the man here don't put the rice in the
sink it's fine it's clean it's clean I
need a clean plate for my shrimp Oh
clean plate thank you kind sir
okay we're kill it we're killing it
right now we're killing it killing it
killing it right now one you came coming
with second puke on the way I know right
don't let the price burn you got it you
got thrown my way
I need that shrimp Oh on a plate I will
rice you in a moment
plate there we go eat [ __ ] I got that
okay we needs to place for the trip way
oh [ __ ] plate plate there's the rice I
[ __ ] it you know you're good just put
some more plates on that on that shrimp
and we got this you got it I think serve
you serve that plate Marquis boys good
[ __ ] 1100 points cooking cooking cooking
cooking I say we do good this game said
great you seem surprised you know it's
family game of the year this is really
cool I don't remember the first one
being this fun but this is fun mark is
green I'm green he's the Asian yeah
Kevin level look we're a boat
however of us look we're a boat look
we're a bus is this Fortin boat bus boat
bus but alright
oh you press the switch and then up oh
yeah I didn't door it Dora the explora
de but you were supposed to find the
button because it's a big mystery where
the [ __ ] button is you see the green
button Ellen's not even where is it Oh
God so the cabin ones are harder and the
recipes are more complicated okay so
this is a we're making like steamed buns
so you you have to eat the fish you just
put the fish in the steamer and cook the
fish but there's also like shrimp and
carrots maybe and you have to put a bag
of flour and an ingredient into the
mixer and then you put the mixing bowl
into the steamer okay two two fishes
we've got the self you construct me a
fish if you want me to chop whatever
I'll be plates again to go thank you
you also have to serve unfortunately oh
no we have to oh no wait has the steamer
[ __ ] alright you've got I've got like
everything steamed oh boy the [ __ ]
alright alright so next up is two beefs
so we can chop the beef mark and put
that beef in our mixer wait can you
throw us two bags of flour oh [ __ ] I
know I [ __ ] it's fine it's fine
so we need two more beefs mark okay you
have to serve the cook stuff also wood
oh god I've got a lot to do here yeah
top right is service so whatever we can
do for you let us know and we'll try and
help but uh okay right we've got the
things you need next okay alright now
put these bowls of beef and your
steamers next and bring you the bowl
back to me yeah thank you and then you
need to chop a fish for the next thing
to like prepare it and play its stuff oh
you need to give us dirty dishes when
you get a chance
Wow fine oh yeah so just serve that
bring those to the middle bring those to
the middle and just set them and I'll
put them on plates for you
okay oh geez actually if you if you
leave the steamer in the middle we can
put that beef in the steamer okay I'll
do the dish
I mean beef and one steamer and fish and
the other ones that yeah yeah so you got
your fish and you got your beef so cook
cook those bad boys and then once you're
done cooking serve those two at the top
right there yeah it's fine it's fine
it's here you're flying with an expert
it's okay boys I just keep going Bob
chop that fish oh I don't like being the
solo guy so we need to beef next marks
oh you're doing that look at you look at
me look at me look at me look at look at
me give us the dirties as well you got
it I can't throw these fish or food so
mark these go and the steamers okay oh
well you can do the dishes that's
whatever I got it I got it
so cook those way just cook those and
we'll try and get these last two out
mark get the plates in the middle and
we'll try it and expedite the service so
just bring the steamers over I'll play
them and then you serve them as fast as
we can
you got it huh serve that one serve that
one serve this one serve this one we did
good we do not get the third star what's
oh my god Wade you really cut it yeah I
don't know how much faster I could go
much faster Wade obviously well so now
now we've reached a decision point boys
are we playing for three stars or are we
playing for guard JP we're doing all
four people I don't know three people I
don't know you guys I guess three people
I'm all right we understand it now my
chat saying Wade you need to dash more
not me though I'm dashing perfectly yes
we're such good at this sitting there
and then serve this if you could get the
dishes for me got it
and that beef is ready to cook okay okay
those are mixing all right doing all
right
we're definitely faster than we were
last time oh yeah boys they're so good
it is nice nice nice nice nice nice nice
yeah nice okay I'm trying to juggle
everything I just want everything ready
to go so many tries words we got flying
we are oh [ __ ] this has [ __ ] in it
Oh trash it trash it oh I had to say
something that was my fault guy yeah
we're all right all right just get a
fish out get a fish out if you just get
that next one out honestly I don't even
know if you have to as long as we don't
lose another order we have enough points
to get this up right now if you want all
right I don't know if it'll make it in
time but you're gonna try all right so
we got the place in the middle here away
- you ready servant servant servant
servant - all right there we are it was
real that is what we are talking about
actual dollars I know that would be nice
audience at home you have to match us
tip for tip that's how it works right
conveyer belts all right so we're gonna
have to throw some [ __ ] around this one
hey beat it - oh yeah - dashing is also
good so I'm gonna throw you some rice is
okay yeah and get that get that going in
those pots off and then we need a air
vent you got to your first one is cuke
serving next one is fish then we got
cute fish again serving I'm gonna tell
you some more rice wood that's not
really in a convenient spot for you
intercepted it thank you
you just stand there way I could start
chopping spoke dirty dish we've gotten
we've got everything we need chopped oh
yeah I will serve this we just need rice
we've got two right spots done just
spots right got it
fish is not first my bad wait sorry
sorry
lagging a wagon a wagon to do I guess
try to get my race I'm trying to like
help you but I'm not sure what you need
I got everything
there's more dishes in the sink for your
great companion a good friend no I know
the great companion good friend you just
friends get sorry what's going on sorry
everything's fine don't worry about it
sorry I got way too listen this is my
job now I've got so much rice that's
ready oh my
my ears are dying of way you know rice
infestation that's what I said that's
standby right that's it yeah okay I
could use more rice I guess which I'm
afraid to take there's too cooked pie
oops where are you who are you who are
you where are you I just hit you no
matter which way he just barrels me as
much as I barrel hit him like it's it's
it's just kind of a mutual barrel okay
that was like some lag because I was on
mice
that sounds like a person one more
possibly I think we're boned alright I
got the rice wait get out of the way get
out of the way good Bob the Bob Bob I
don't want to bone your ass don't don't
don't
I'll give it a try I'll give it a trial
I'll try anything once
what boned no bone your ass all right
yeah don't can we at least monetize it
on pornhub so I can pay my taxes next
year we need to find the yellow button
okay um what about that flower patch up
top oh the ground is yellow that wait no
yellow button bug the spoon of the four
that's right fork right spoon in the
fork over there left is yellow yellow
button it all the one all the buttons
buttons buttons but all right guys I
don't think this is working I think we
might reassess hidden flowers by that
pig tree Yeah right there did the field
there like the story of the somme bread
just like the Umbra bread oh I hate
myself I hate everything that's
happening here I hate all of you most
importantly I hate this also there's
gonna be a hate boning that we're gonna
do past us all right so you gotta put
the passes in the waters got put some
tomatoes in the pan and maybe some
Nastasia so no one-man show is just
doing everything all right the balloon
sometimes leaves no no it's it's you can
go both places you're not alone Oh the
balloons sometimes leaves oh yeah see
how the right balloon is like that's
very helpful it you took the pasta
through thank you story if the balloon
leaves I'm gonna store some pasta right
see you see
the pastas burning where am i why am i
over here wait what don't do that what
are you doing I'm not do you don't know
where you are don't touch things I was
being that I wasn't you know oh I don't
want to question this restaurants
motives but like what are we serving -
exactly yeah are we dropping it off the
don't don't wait don't touch it the
tomatoes is not for you well we need
clean dishes I'm getting them on it I'm
on it I'm on it I'm on three two one
grab it oh yeah there's a pasta
I'll serve this BAM
I got a pasta cook tomato Oh a Turk lows
Oh getting squid I'm good is this one
done can we serve this tomato
yeah serve that serve that I got thanks
you got it buddy you got we need some
dishes like real bad I got you covered I
got you covered baby I got you covered
and we just don't have many dishes in
this round I suppose all right cool the
dishes oh all right I got a pasta wait
right [ __ ] here give me the pasta on
my dish they're holding a pot of pasta
my plays such a tease you bill I'm gonna
put the pasta on the thing I did already
oh okay good can't tell sometimes you
don't did it already did it and you
didn't do that [ __ ] I'm in the wrong
place
[ __ ]
what's wrong with the fire extinguisher
it was in my way burning let it burn
probably plates what what do you need
mark plates that's not a cutting board
for my doom of my life plate you need a
bass player
I'll get you baby wait wait wait I got
cut off I got cut I couldn't potted
plate you can't hold you get a pot and
play you want watch too hot that's true
that's true
I've had the thought about the pot you
could not drop the hottest but I could
not don't be it's what you sought now if
Ross lost it Cole I can't serve salads
e.coli I mean know what could happen
eat coli is it really bad that bad seems
bad I've got friends with e.coli and I
think they're fine my best friends are
equal oh [ __ ] it's a thing I said
[ __ ] ecoli restaurant coming up
Tamara I don't know why I did this but I
did it
mark put on a plate [ __ ] oh there's fire
now oh boy fire prevents you from higher
you served it out of order you dumb
piece of [ __ ] listen I may be a dumb
piece of [ __ ] but at least I respect my
friends Jesus give it to me what why is
the fire problem
it's a [ __ ] when these dishes but the
dishes are on fire or something there we
go all right hot hot spicy spicy give me
the lettuce the fire's pushing me away
from the dishes they're cut the white
surface
all done boys I don't know don't be a
[ __ ] don't be a little [ __ ] baby
what hey what's wrong with serving
dishes mark mark was mark was throwing
lettuce mark was torn a little lettuce
tantrum no I was trying to be supply it
you know somebody serve a lettuce tomato
or just set a plate down next to it
that's fine do it
sorry oh I'm sorry I'm sorry need a
lettuce first don't you don't you I did
it I did it
[Music]
it works grosses me out
I guess it's fine is is good oh we don't
need this [ __ ] you need you did the
lettuce right there's a that's not okay
Oh what you did all right now we're
better Oh sushi sushi I don't I've got
the thing - lettuce tomato and a cute
I'm getting it I'm getting no not in the
trash Oh God
nori nori nori Dory fish oh [ __ ]
fish Wade I swear to god I'm the only
one doing the right thing can't be wrong
I knew I couldn't make a good guys okay
rice um
rice somebody take this rice I got the
other race right here set it down set it
down
that's nori I have nori okay first up is
right
[Laughter]
burn that's why don't act like I'm a
dumbass cooked rice a slave and a cube
and a nori tomato just gone are we done
with tomato tomato God Nick so there you
go you got that right fishies can you
where's the fish
I didn't like that fish it was looking
at me wrong
rice want rice rice there's rice rice on
the cutting board rice rice fish sushi
out we got no more rice cooking so our
days you guys don't even need me to make
death threats words are salt
dysfunctional in our own ways our
hot-air balloon crashed into a sushi
restaurant and we were just like you got
a cook word when you got a cook
it's like chefs code we killed all the
chefs in there so we have to we have to
finish what they started what would guy
ramsay gordon ramsay dude bear grylls
think about this oh we got to go back to
castle guy why okay who wants it because
it says I don't know looking like I know
why I'm gonna touch Kevin some work
come here Kevin you're cute ducky I'm a
[ __ ] on yeah Kevin hey someone talked
to the onion what an adventure you've
been [ __ ] still have more to learn
about cooperation you [ __ ] heading
to the wild country I hear their [ __ ]
out there
Clark that wasn't me that was dog [ __ ]
stop dog
wait you okay alone you guys have to
leave I'm not gonna stop touching Kevin
till we leave I won't touch the dog no
my Kevin my Kevin no tachi Kevin no one
but me
there get up there oh here come oh we
can do it let's break it so we're all
touching Kevin I'm getting there ocean
that's not right
it's okay our bus turns into a boat oh
[Laughter]
sorry I just forgot about that detail I
was so excited and turned on by it what
impression did I want you to do that you
refused to do because I think that was
pretty clear
Iago I deal with Godfrey - welcome -
let's have a date oh [ __ ] we gotta throw
stuff to each other this time I'm sorry
so chop some [ __ ] Wade and then throw
back we gotta cook that [ __ ] I'm being
swamped and [ __ ] is not necessarily the
best thing oh I threw that potato in the
park I watched you throw my [ __ ]
fries away I'm gonna swamp them with
stuff so you know there's some more
chicken there's some more chicken same
champion man same chicken it's goddamn
taters taters chuckles ooh taters I'm
chucking mark put some taters in the
goddamn fryolator okay fry now fryer you
later guys a fryer I know I can't grab
the one that's mark don't serve that yet
I wasn't gonna I wasn't gone okay okay
now I serve it sir okay good good
chicken shake chicken
serves fry up the chicken taters I don't
have we don't don't act like you're
doing it all I'm doing just as much as
you doing every single [ __ ] thing no
actually it's kind of working pretty
well
I can't endure Can I grab this with my
hand it seemed yeah you can that's not
in there you guys mine this fire is not
in here I got this hey I move
moving on I'm moving I like to think
I've contributed as much as awesome you
have not I might be able to get this one
oh no the chicken no it's chicken no the
answer is no I was wrong answer is no
definitely not iago you don't see that
no goofy singing ever since I've always
thought that the goofy voice is an
underrated voice in this era people need
to really bring that back oh [ __ ] boys
we got to find a green button oh all
right blue this slide we threw the flag
we just did green that's the only green
that I see the grass grass tree the
grass
all right this pits already sold for me
under self obviously two inches away
from the ramp
seriously overcooked guys I love your
game but that was not worth the time
that took you to code that in I don't
think there's any six-month-olds playing
overcooked oh sweet ever-loving Jesus oh
my god sake it's getting chopped chop
chop chop go snake dick is going to get
all cooked that south steak do it thing
yeah keep going wait I'm really tapping
my toes into this one we did a fishy
shrimp cooked shrimp go we're going to
do wind Oh God
am i helping yeah sure yeah yeah I need
oh [ __ ]
shrimp raw pasta on this plate it's not
raw if it's on the plate it's cooked
it's awesome I threw it away
mark put the plate down I swear to god
wait uh that's the trouble over here
guys didn't know you can do that mark
you're the only one who do what do you
need from me anything we got we need a
beef pasta beef beef beef everywhere out
pasta bah bah bah bah de I can't throw
the pastas done wait do the thing I
thought you were getting the thing it's
just trying to cut fish to the shrimp
fish shrimp coming up organizing this
thank you cook pasta on the thing
weights doing a job second would you you
got it if I fall off with this it goes
away right off who's checking checking
checking shrimp and shrimp and shrimp
and fish you know one of them's repping
fish don't yell at me the only one who
attention I just yell all right shrimp
it I threw that off the edge shrimp and
fish next serve a beef next got shrimp
and fish cook it up get the beef wait
the beef that's cooked get it oh why did
you take the plate away from the pan to
set the place offers work
I wasn't working to meet I didn't know
all right
nailed it
we were positive about that we mean my
father guys Bob we're doing great right
yeah I feel good about this shrimp a
fish that's gonna be the name of the
restaurant that we make together guys
shrimp it fish shrimp and fish are we
doing a restaurant exists for this is
the precursor to our restaurant yeah
nobody is eating at a restaurant called
three peens
mbw the food you cut out a lot that's
what I said okay
ah [ __ ] oh god damn it wait for us past
us past is past us PSS PSS PSS thank you
pastors thank you nan mushroom you had
the right idea yeah I'm really good or
Bob I'm really gonna turn a leaf on this
one I'm really gonna I'm gonna be
focused one yeah I'm gonna be focused
I'm gonna be ready look BAM possible
little beautiful little boy need pasta
give me pasta cook good yeah Chuck some
psst right in my hand
Chuck is right in the bucket pretty
close so you have to serve Wade so at
the bottom there the dishes are gonna
come back to you on a table so you have
to serve those and you all I think you
also have to do dishes got it that's
just okay just a little bit of
everything he can do it he's the man
he's the man he's the man he's the man
was bland Molly just want step that'd be
awesome I can't grab God food again
didn't you sorry
Molly brought food no no I know what she
brought it was overcooked it's thematic
Wow you're gonna you're gonna just call
out
Molly's Molly's a gracious gift of food
to you like that yes I'm calling out
Molly for windy place wait
plates real bad got it got it got it got
it got it better answer dishes at the
bottom while they're over there yeah set
a clean plate if you can and and do that
but we're officially backed up on plates
here are we don't need more pasta Nexus
mushroom steak well actually we have it
we have it just focus on serving the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I need to serve this mushroom
ASAP
oh I just missed it I just missed it
yeah check us two pastas we got to
justice coming your way I didn't get any
clean plates at all backed up on plates
alright so we got the next two dishes
after these two you're about to serve
ready to go oh just serve those quick 15
seconds and then give us the other plate
I guess I think it's gonna be too slow
yeah I feel good about this I feel good
about this this was good this was good
five five forty seven is pretty good
right yeah I hope so yeah yeah we killed
it we killed it
[Music]